Let's look at some interesting posts that I saw
this morning on The David Pakman Show sub Reddit,
which you can find at David Pakman dotcom
slash Reddit more than what is the number. Now,
more than 28000 viewers and listeners of
the show now subscribe to the sub. Read it
at David Pakman dot com. Read it. A lot of
people writing to me after the first day of
the Trump impeachment trial. Number two about
the so-called Chewbacca defense. After seeing
attorney Bruce Castor rant for 50 minutes, Trump's
attorney, Bruce Castor rant for 50 minutes about
vinyl records that his parents liked the
political preferences of his parents,
his friends in the Senate, and what kind of
relationships he has with them, prerevolutionary
British law and all sorts of things that have
nothing to do whatever with the impeachment
trial. I got a bunch of emails from people saying
was that the Chewbacca defense and scrapie do
posted this to the Subrata saying, Who believes
that Bruce Castor was attempting to use the
Chewbacca defense during yesterday's portion
of former President Trump's impeachment trial
and pointing out that Bruce Castor speech was
just random facts and irrelevant things to the
actual defense of Donald Trump. And indeed, the
Chewbacca defense is a legal strategy. There's
actually an entire wiki page about the Chewbacca
defense. The Chewbacca defense is a legal strategy
when a criminal lawyer just tries to confuse
the jury instead of refuting the case. And the
reason that this can work in criminal trials is
we have the standard of reasonable doubt. And
if a defense attorney can introduce reasonable
doubt, any kind of reasonable doubt,
then they are a significant step closer to
securing an acquittal for their client. And
so the idea of a Chewbacca defense would be
a prosecution comes together and makes a case
that's relevant and it's germane to the facts
and the complaint that is being adjudicated.
And a defense attorney can introduce irrelevant
facts, stories, confusion. And if you can get
the jurors just saying, well, we had the case from
the prosecution and then we had the case from the
defense, even if the case from the defense
was irrelevant and didn't make any sense,
if it makes the jurors feel as though there's
some kind of doubt as to what happened, even if
it's because the defense lawyer was talking about
Chewbacca, Star Wars, vinyl records and whatever,
you can turn what might be a very good case for
the prosecution into a confusing enough case
that maybe you get a juror to say, I think we've
got to go with not guilty because I'm still even
confused about what it is that took place. That's
the that's the idea of the Chewbacca defense.
Now, it shouldn't really apply to a Senate
impeachment trial where the standards are
different. It is not a criminal proceeding.
It is a political proceeding. The jury is not,
you know, six or 12 of one's peers. It's 100 U.S.
senators. So in any case, that's the back story
on the Chewbacca defense. And it is in practice, I
don't know that Bruce Castor deliberately planned
to go up there and do what Chewbacca defense,
but it's ultimately what ended up taking place.
Another interesting post on the Subrata this
morning about the second impeachment where user
H.H. 231 said the second impeachment will be like
the movie Groundhog Day. Same type of honestly
presented facts by Democrats as in the first
impeachment, followed by the same lame falsehoods
and distractions by Republicans as in the first
impeachment. Same disappointing results still
needs to happen, though, and I hope I'm wrong
about the results now. You know, in the first
impeachment, I was saying pretty early Trump's not
getting convicted and we knew that because we knew
that they weren't going to have the votes. You
need 17 Republicans to say I'm going to vote to
convict. And we thought there might be somewhere
between one and four. And in the end, Mitt Romney
voted to convict on one of the two counts, much
the same way. I know that people get mad at me
when I say this. And they've been emailing me this
week saying, David, why are you prejudging what's
going on and saying there won't be a conviction.
It's because we know that maybe there would be
five very optimistically, five or six Republicans
that might vote to convict. On the single count
in question here in the current impeachment trial,
but we just know Democrats don't have the numbers,
we just know I would love to be able to tell you
that it's too early because every Republican is
going in there planning to evaluate the case
made by the impeachment managers and evaluate
the case made by Donald Trump's attorneys and
then going to decide by weighing the evidence.
But that's not what they're going to do. We
know that that's not what they're going to do.
And remember that 44 members of the Senate
already said they don't even believe the Senate
has the jurisdiction to do this trial.
You think they're really open to voting
to convict Donald Trump? Of course not.
So I know some people don't like it,
but it's the reality and Donald Trump will be
acquitted. The question is, will he be acquitted
with any Republican votes going against him or
will he be acquitted with every Republican vote in
his favor remains to be seen. Join the discussion
on the sub. Read it at David Pakman Dotcom it.